spain was one of the world's most
successful imperial powers having
conquered much of south america the
wealth it gained from this empire made
it europe's most powerful nation for a
time but in the late 19th century when
the great powers of europe opted to
carve up africa between themselves spain
despite its history was only apportioned
these lands which raises the question
why why didn't spain get more of africa
so a quick thing to note about the
berlin conference it wasn't something
which created immutable borders that
everyone agreed to and would stick to
forever after it was just a forum to set
up principles and let countries work it
out between themselves hopefully without
warfare and the reason why spain didn't
get much was fairly simple it didn't
meet the two criteria the countries
involved in the conference had largely
agreed to the first of which was the
nation's historic claim to any of the
land if you previously had any outposts
thoughts or settled any regions you'd
have a strong claim and this is where
spain fell short as many of you will
know when europeans were exploring the
world and seeing which parts of it they
wanted for themselves the spanish and
portuguese reached a deal and this was
formalized under the guidance of the
pope in the treaty of tordesias which
split the world into two the spanish
half and the portuguese half which
you'll notice contains africa hence why
spain never made much of an effort to
settle or conquer it now spain did have
some lands in northern africa which were
respected by the conference and it also
had these lands off the western coast
which under an agreement with france
became this this was basically all spain
would get but as you'll note there were
many nations which had zero history in
africa that also got territory for
example belgium which had only existed
for like five minutes at this point and
there were also states which did have
historic links to the region like the
netherlands who got nothing and the
reason why is the second criteria which
countries could enforce their claims the
dutch had a claim to southern africa but
it was currently under the control of
britain who needed it to keep shipping
lanes open to india and britain was more
than willing to fight a war to keep it
that way spain to use the technical term
was broke by this point as such spain
couldn't afford the immense costs of
creating and defending any large
colonies in africa and he had done very
little in the way of exploration and for
spain things only got worse after 1884.
spain's economy didn't improve for
decades the country was politically
divided and its international prestige
was all but gone now spain did want
territory and hoped to gain more of it
from morocco whereas france had other
ideas france opted to acknowledge the
spanish claim to this and gave it
economic access to morocco in return for
the spanish helping them put down
rebellions and in the end this was all
spain got it didn't have any recognized
historic claims to the continent it
didn't have the economic or military
power to enforce any new ones and unlike
belgium and portugal it didn't have the
international goodwill to play the
greater powers off of each other for
their own benefit i hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
with a special thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly money maker mr
wolf sky chappelle core show wolf jerry
lambda adam stalter jordan longley rod
the martin wyan hockey spencer lightfoot
captain cydog marvin castle gustav swan
boogiely wiggly words about books
podcast robert wetzel winston cayward
aaron the white matthew shipley alex
schwinn maggie paxkowski corey turner
anthony beckett coppertone the mcwhopper
spinning three plates charles the first
ben evinson and scottish trekkie